bella e più di ragazzi e benvenuti
questo video sono fa vj non ci siamo su
un layer software un gioco dove piove e
non ai l'ombrello cioè una roba anche
figure o subito tra l'altro è la madonna
che grafica e ultimamente stanno facendo
degli horror della madonna ria che bel
culetto che sanno fare a si apre proprio
mamma papà l'ha fatto di nuovo ti
tradisce con un topo è il cora qui
troppo del cazzo
dove ma come mai su così figo tenuti in
cucina e lurido vai che vuoi fare
ratatouille
ora che io so cucinare solo un panino al
prosciutto e gli viene anche male tra
l'altro dai ragazzi fate vedere che bei
quadri certo ma anche di squadra se
avessi una casa così sarebbero tutti
così quadriga attaccare al muro
ovvio rai che oggi vi sono qualcosa
ragazzi siete pronti e dove sarebbe
fiero di me bastardo noi che va a fan
culo e ram bottiglie ma si abbassi la
pista porta
sapevo che la chiave a prima qualcosa
può disegnare quindi so fare queste cose
no veramente una merda però lo venderò
comunque a 2 milioni di euro aveva
affanculo lasciamo che il senso di stan
stanza non la sto capendo anche
ma chi è che ha chiuso cosa cosa sta
succedendo e quel topo del cazzo colpa
sua ha cambiato tutta la casa mi sta
prendendo per il culo stop deficiente di
qua e vabbè che cazzo ne so io 666 satan
ha illuminati conferma caso accesissimo
no non ci credo una possibilità su mille
di riuscirci sisto riuscita al terzo
tentativo a caso è possibile
ciao fratello ha tanto lo so già su casi
osserva più da vicino mi sposerai ti
ringrazio tantissimo per la proposta zio
però sono maschio pro grazie
non mi fate vedere più un quadro in
tutta la mia vita ragazzi non lo voglio
vedere cioè cd mettiamo skrillex one two
three
[Musica]
i lati negli scaffali cazzo può uscire
di skrillex perché hai smesso di suonare
i prometti che non ti sciogli più se
prendo questa cosa ti prego possiamo
uscire a questa stanza del cazzo vi
prego perché è partito da solo sto coso
ragazzi vabbè io esco lo stesso grazie è
stato bello ciao si capisce un pene da e
vi prego se qualcuno mi cercasse sono in
burundi alla prossima perché sparisce
tutto quando mi girano la bella cosa che
non certo [ __ ] vaffan malware non
l'orata io la porta mi sto sfasciando
casa purina siete pronti a ricominciare
a scuola ragazzi questo è quello che vi
aspetta abbandona la speranza fin che
può e cos'è tipo lasciate ogni speranza
voi che entrate
io lascio anche sta minkia mo che entro
però il problema non è quello che mi
spuntano di persone no no no no no no no
no no no tu vai giù vai giù copy
nell'acqua niente bagno per me guarda a
bravo torna giovedì obbedisci bravo così
gli stronzi che figata assurda di topi
ma io un bagnetto me lo farei ragazzi
non sono io che posso esco pro grazie
per avermi offerto questo bagno ma
mancava il sapone di marsiglia
ecco questo è il corridoio della mia
scuola quando l'inizio dopo l'estate
uguale prof
troppo fatti compiti e sa che ho fatto i
compiti prof
deva lo stesso questore sora
professoressa guardi che ho fatto tutto
è chiudo la porta è pro e se non c'è
casino dal corridoio visto che bravo mi
dà 10 in condotta grazie insomma
cortesia sempre prof
ascolti e no no no no però c'è un limite
a tutto ragazzi cè un lì
posso ragazzi no vabbè buttare lo sapevo
lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo
sei bella sei maiorca guarda la mia prof
era molto più brutta di beck reding ok
bene bene sto scherza era una roba tanto
per
ecco questo succede quando mi
interrogano stessa che poi mi risveglio
che non mi ricordo che mi chiamo ecco
costa invece quando non c'è la prof
le sedie finiscono così nella mia classe
uguale bello ciao si chiudano si
chiudeva dato ma chi cazzo credi di far
paura
so che a abela reds in quanto sei bel
molonia lì ti sposerei tre volte bello
vai da un dentista nylon del teaser che
si proprio mi tocca le vostre mani le
accetto brava se sta roba perché c'è un
bambino attaccato un quadro ciao frate
scalda zio e ti posso toccare giuggiola
non sto scherzando
sto scherzando è perché sono caduto cioè
nel senso ha cambiato il corridoio di
prima ecco bravo cerca la [ __ ] bravo zio
ragazzi ce ne stiamo andando grazie
grazie mille molto bello
stiamo andando ragazzi sicily stiamo
andando ragazzi ci siamo proprio
andandomi concetto che minchia york
[ __ ] stavo dicendo che di arte non
me ne intendo c'è un motivo c'era un
motivo se avevo 4 a scuola d arte
maledizione in cassino che succede
eccolo il bastardo ma dove vai se un
suicidato nel fuoco bravo zio
[ __ ] ma [ __ ] dov'è che stiamo
andando
viene da qua ragazzi mamma ora che lo ha
ucciso è il top three tranquilla dove
vado a destra sinistra ragazzi decidete
voi destra sinistra avete detto tutti
sinistra bravi quando c'è il pavimento
bagnato non è mai un buon segno
qualsiasi gioco sia ancora qui a caso ok
ok
si vabbè ciao sono file j
mamma buone notizie ho fatto la spesa
avevo portato tanta frutta tanto che
cos'è best bauer uscire c'è un ascensore
anch'io lo vogliono ascensori in casa
che figura
salve mamma mamma quella e mamma che va
a vedere se ho fatto la spesa
l'importante che non ci spunti davanti a
noi
poi per il resto è va bene così perché
vedo giallo cane quando fu fini buono è
il quadro bello fu guarda preferivo il
topo arrosto antiche cane però avere lo
stesso telefono che squilla dove
bastardi oddio oddio io pronto pizza una
capricciosa grazie una quattro formaggi
e senza prosciutto è meno toccati
una vacca lo sapevo se avrei scommesso
la vita eterna che lo sapevo ecco luca e
un camion salva mia nonna anche uguale
la porta via
ho sempre porte di legno adesso bianca o
che bella questa
dio mio pian piano vedi detto qualcosa o
trovo eccola centro ho trovato il casinò
del carlino in perfetto in dio dove
infilare né alcuno del carillon
fantastico io non sto tocca già mi
spunta qualcosa per forza cosa miglia
che chi è chi che brutti giocattoli
regali comprati in poi o mio dio bel
quadro
no ragazzi state state generando è stata
generando calmi ragazzo buzzico
diciamola papà di riparare la finestra
grazie
eccolo successo un paio vabbè ha preso
un brutto voto ragazzi che vi devo dire
ciao ciao del disegno loro ioni non mi
fate cagare in mano e non mi fate kagari
ma io ve lo dico
gli schiaffi moda non ha chance baby
everything is on line ciao e le stelle
la carne va bene [ __ ]
ciao seme bei giocatori che arriva per
farti saltare la testa non mi toccare
dio non so che bello che sei d'accordo
ragazzi concludo che questo primo
episodio di riley e rock come cazzo si
chiama lei un figlio è veramente figo
non vedo l'ora di vedere veramente non
la vedo l'ora
preferisco evitare prova ma continuerà
peggio e questo è un dato di fatto però
vabbè concludo episodio per stavolta
spero che ha visto vi sia piaciuto e
cosa sento ragazzi 6 video è piaciuto
lasciato momento mi piace anche a pagina
di facebook e con i video tra la notizia
se no se avessi discreto e ci vediamo al
prossimo vibo bel ragazzo